then I started a non-profit dozen
schools in Africa amazing you're just a
may overhear what do you do I teach be
crumbs and Yossef low and such any other
goals I really want to get pregnant
great wonderful I'm gonna go what do you
want to do well this is nice we could
talk I like talking not the big 12
looking and I'm not done in two nice
okay that's my best friend Jen how's
this for new gen asked me to have a baby
with her that is so Brooklyn look great
oh shut up gained like four pounds since
you saw me last should I just put it in
a turkey baster I don't even have a
turkey baster how do you want to do this
I want to do it the old-fashioned way
sure take my bra oh god no I can't
believe you didn't ask me our child
would be gazing we've been talking about
it forever I know city needs more
children you're sure you don't want to
wait around for the right guy to come
along wait around for the right straight
guy in new york city girl it looks so
sad
so how was proving to yourself that you
could still do it with a woman shave my
legs and I realized I probably didn't
have to surprisingly easy it seems so
early for a midlife crisis and yet here
we are you're the only man for me that's
I make a loose leaf tea that helps
increases sex drive like taking these
verbs they're making me feel like all
sorts weird oh my god dance yes what
kind of weird it's like crazy horny
weird you want to have sex I've got like
half an hour to kill kill it at work
today the woman L with me in the brass
Bryce creamed how might it your breasts
aren't sensitive Heather we're pregnant
I just kind of had sex with someone else
you know the condom broke homewrecker
there's a really small chance that the
baby might be his prize
it does not matter whose sperm it was
that baby is worse and jams
Oh gay Republicans is so cool you
shouldn't lie about Tommy there's room
for all shades of gay under the rainbow
because there's no